how to market a new concept
so got a great email from one of my
newsletter subscribers love you guys
jerry who wrote in to say good morning
mr carmichael i recently came across
your postings on youtube and i've been
following
you ever since first let me thank you
for your work and your assistance the
entrepreneur community
thank you jerry as a person who has
failed in business many times i've
continued and pushed forward regardless
i don't waste your time but i have a
question and this may take a few minutes
of your time
i've been in the transportation
logistics field for over 10 years i've
expanded
and contracted a few times over the
years i've serviced retail clients such
as ashley furniture home depot sears and
a few others
but what i found is that most people or
delivery contractors don't have a steady
crew working with them
but the main issue is most can't find
help at a moment's notice
which sometimes in this business is
vital i have an idea to create an app
to help unskilled labor such as those in
constructions at carpentry
delivery services to link up with
available hands and workers
i need to know how would i market this
app i don't want to charge right off
because
i want to build the network of unskilled
labor first then as i get more exposure
maybe start charging fee to the
companies or business professionals who
need immediately help
this is sort of like a staffing agency
only i want instant results for those
who need help right away
how do i market this concept again i
love what you're doing keep up the great
work evan
jerry so jerry's a great question and
congratulations on
having the guts to go for and launch
your own business around this area
i wouldn't start with an app my number
one rule for you here
is start small number one is start small
don't start with an app
okay because an app is gonna cost you
money and what you need to do is test
this thing
is there actually a need for this so you
think there's a need is there actually
need will unskilled labor
give you their their contact information
and
then will the home depot or sears
whoever pay you
to make that service happen right and
you could start it without an
app start it just by getting people's
phone numbers and you can send text
messages to them
they're probably more likely to pay
attention to a text than to
an app anyway but you could start that
right now right you could start building
your list of unskilled laborers and say
hey
if you ever want to do delivery services
or whatever services
last minute i need people here's how
much approximately you're going to make
from it
give me your phone number and i'll text
you anytime i get a job
that's how you start and you build your
list and you ask them for friends
and you you start small you're testing
it you see if it works
okay don't go spending money on an app
that that you lose time on you're
investing your dollars into and you
don't know if it's gonna work or not
right and so many entrepreneurs go down
that road where they say here's my new
plan i'm gonna invest all these
all these dollars in time into creating
this thing and then it doesn't work out
where it's better to test it right away
on a small scale as quickly as you can
so that's my advice start off get their
phone numbers send texts
and it's manual but if it doesn't work
out
you're not dumping money into this thing
right if it doesn't work out it's just
a little bit of your time wasted number
two start local
start with a geographic area close to
you is going to be
easy and ideal and again we're testing
this thing out on a small scale
local workers okay you target the the
you know 10 local home depots and sears
and all that that are close to you
and the local workers who are all around
you and you start with them
you see if it works you see if you can
get them to sign up you see if you can
get them to
give you their their phone number so you
can send them text messages
that's going to be the easier side right
to get their information to say hey i
may have a job for you
send me your number and i can send you a
text when we have something
that should be the easier side it's then
can you deliver to
the home depot so home depot calls and
says hey yeah we need
three people to come and deliver this
thing can you actually
deliver and so you test local
test small you're to make some mistakes
you figure it out along the way
and then as you move up
number three is you prove the concept
right you're going to make mistakes
along the way
home depot is going to say you know you
didn't get me my people in time or
they're the wrong people or
they didn't do what i asked or they
didn't speak english or whatever the
criteria
is that they need right you're going to
make mistakes
but you're going to learn from them and
you're going to make it better and maybe
the solution
is going to be hey we need an app for
this maybe the solution is that the
unskilled workers
they would love an app and maybe the
home depot guys would love to be able to
log in and just
press a few buttons and have some
workers show up
right maybe that's the end solution but
you're not going to know that
right now right prove the concept show
that it works
and then you can slowly expand and see
if like the home depot guy is even going
to pay you for this
if you go out you talk about marketing
this concept if you go out and
you get some people a job they're going
to spread the word for you
right so in my city toronto i have
we have a large filipina community and
a lot of them are nannies and
we had a nanny for a while and when
there are jobs
they talk to each other there's a whole
community right there's a lot of
filipinos here they love to share
and a lot of the jobs that that are on
the market they never even get posted
because they share and talk to each
other
so if you get a few people in and you
get them a job through a relationship
that you have
they're gonna share they're gonna spread
that word for you and say
yeah messages scott email this guy call
this guy and get added to his list
and every time he has a job he's going
to send you a message
so start small start local prove the
concept
make your mistakes without spending a
lot of money
and then invest in expanding this thing
once you prove it in your local area
to go national and take over the world
because that's how jerry does
believe those are watching like the
video support me by clicking on the link
in the description
leave a comment let me know what you
think and click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much
i'll see you soon